all right things just got wild in Hunter
Hunter this admittedly was a very text
Heavy installment lots of introductions
to new characters abilities and all
sorts of complex political Dynamics all
of which adds up to a very game-changing
chapter let's get into it wrapping up
the adventures of Henry and Wang we are
introduced to a new nanability possessed
by the old man whose name I still don't
think we know yet what we do know is at
the very least he is a level 21 meaning
that this helpless old man has killed at
least 21 people allegedly helpless
allegedly according to him he's a con
man he's not to be trusted but he
appears to be capable of creating a nen
clone unfortunately my Japanese
onomatopoeia game isn't pretty pathetic
so I can't tell exactly what the
substance is here that the Clone was
created out of it could be fire could be
smoke could be Vapor could be any of the
other things I haven't said but given
that the Clone does become a substance
there's the potential of this ability
involving transmutation or conjuration
like transmuting your aura into a
substance and then Conjuring a body out
of it but what holds me back from that
idea is that there's likely manipulation
involved as well which I just think is
one too many disciplines for an amateur
you know all of the mixing and matching
but then again maybe not contagion might
have just done all of the oromats for
him like the old man thinks to himself
hmm I want an ability that does that
does this then contagion just says yeah
yeah sure thing buddy don't worry I've
got you covered what I do find very
fascinating is that the random Chara guy
who we know is a Chara member because
he's the same dude that Wang ordered to
bring the money previously but he states
that nameless old man might have a
similar ability to the boss and at first
I thought oh is this some Intrigue on
Wang does wang have some sort of cloning
style ability but in reality he could be
referring to one of three people either
underboss Wang Vice boss to jail or even
the big boss broccoli himself in case
you don't remember yes that is his
actual name broccoli but either way it
was a really stupid thing to say out
loud one because Henry is there and yes
they've got a bit of an alliance
happening right now but he's still from
a rival gang and two because he is
giving this information away in Haley
territory someone could have an ability
ability that's watching and listening to
them in this room right now in which
case the Chara guy man has just given
away extremely valuable information
however I am increasingly enjoying
Henry's presence in this series in the
past three chapters he's been nothing
short of captivating I love his
analytical prowess I love the basic but
versatile and inability and also I think
his design just kinda hits there's a lot
of characters in this Arc that let's be
honest just sort of look like random
dudes I'm not looking at anyone in
particular Haley family so I guess it's
just nice to have a character who always
stands out amongst the glob of Togashi
characters oh and also it's tragically
funny watching short Soldier guy into
the room it's just like mate have you
paid attention to nothing that just
happened here in front of you the answer
to that is no and Henry to his credit
did make a mild effort to stop him you
know he did it like oh wait no don't
don't enter the room but as soon as he
did everyone was all like yeah well he's
dead shall we go for lunch so that's two
people that this trap has now managed to
kill which is bad very bad because there
were at least two Haley members on level
20 so they just needed one more kill
each to develop an inability and one of
them did I believe his name is Billy
with like an e on the end he turned out
to be a conjurer and there's some
interesting commentary from another
member of just how weird it is that
there seems to be a lot of left-handed
conjurers which might be an interesting
little sub fact I know that shizuku is
Left-Handed for example because she used
her right hand to arm wrestle gone which
was her weekend and she she happens to
be a conjurer but then again craft
picker is a conjurer and he appears to
be right-handed because that's where all
of the chains appear all of this
actually reminds me very much of
furykov's affinity test where he claimed
that conjurers and manipulators can be
easily spotted because they tend to keep
their dominant hands free and if we were
to add in The Stereotype of the majority
of contros being left-handed then you
could have a good chance of narrowing it
down to the exact Affinity in that case
sorry I just went on an tangent there I
do that but there's a lot of stuff like
this in the chapter so many references
to previous characters and Concepts that
have very easily forgotten especially
after a three-year Hiatus and one of
those small things happens during the
Haley section Miranda says that they've
lost contact with the person that they
left with ceradnik which I believe is a
reference to what I can only describe as
a pile of bodily goop that we saw in
saradnik's room during chapter 384. and
during that time he was also speaking
about Miranda on the phone so he clearly
just took care of some business in the
most brutal manner possible let's
explain what's happening here though the
Haley family was previously supported by
ceradnik however after Moreno's Mutiny
he now seeks to destroy them after he's
done learning all of his nuns Morena
knows this and wants to plan to spy
amongst his cohort to prevent any
surprises which is a big Revelation in
and of itself being that Morena is
capable of reinfecting with contagion
this is dangerous because it means we
can't just pick off the Haley members
one by one if one Falls then Miranda can
just kiss someone else to take their
place and it also makes the family
members so much more disposable than we
previously thought which puts them in a
perfect position to be taking all sorts
of volatile risks because why not so
this band of amateurs is far more
threatening than I origin originally
thought which was already pretty damn
threatening in general this whole family
is giving me serious ant Vibes
especially with the whole dismemberment
room to dispose of the corpses it's like
a factory production line in the same
way that the ants would Farm humans for
food just significantly more morbid
because at the very least the ants they
were farming humans to eat meanwhile the
Haley guys are just taking lives and
disposing of the leftover meat I also
did love seeing Mirena in a gamer chair
very appropriate as the game master but
also for such a spine tingling figure
Miranda had a couple of cute moments in
this chapter tagashi drawing her with
this very purposely simplistic style not
at all commensurate to her role in the
story oh and just in case you're
wondering the kanji on dog man's head is
Inu which which just means dog he's
interesting because he's an enhancer
which is something that I very rarely
say but there's this whole conversation
about needing more levels and it makes
sense because each level gained gives
the user an aura boost and Dogman as an
enhancer probably doesn't have one of
the Trixie tactical abilities that the
other members do so he's in a position
where it probably just serves him better
to gain more Aura in order to be able to
punch harder and more often I think that
Morena was also spot on about ceradnik
wanting to kill her himself firstly
because saradnik has already promised to
kill one of his siblings with his own
hands and secondly because she is a
woman who betrayed him and that that is
like the absolute worst thing in
seradnikland which leads us to the band
of new characters introduced here the
childhood friends of said seradnik who
have added a whole new layer of depth to
the story I mean I get it this chapter
has lots of text and does bombard you
with a lot of characters honestly
something I definitely don't think is a
strength of tokashi is is the way that
he introduces characters definitely not
that he does it introducing characters
is good but it's the way in which he
does it often times they just appear in
very jarring ways and you need to like
really sit down and invest as a reader
to get to know them and this was one of
those chapters where you only get as
much out as you put in if you don't read
the last ton of text then it is an easy
0 out of 10. but if you do scale the
wall of text then it seriously raises
the stakes and the tension and the
excitement of everything for example a
lot of time is spent conveying the idea
that the Haley family are technically
treated as civilians which would be bad
if one of their bodies were to end up in
the wrong place with the wrong soldier
who files the wrong incident in the
wrong category because then Kaboom
that's right right now the fate of this
entire ship could be decided by a
clerical error and look if that's not
Hunter Hunter then I don't know what is
it's especially problematic because the
kankine police and military may have
their own way of understanding how to
conduct business in a very subtle manner
but the hunter Association is completely
different part of their contract is very
specifically to protect the princes
which may lead to the decision that it's
in their best interest to eliminate the
mafia families if they get any sort of
whiff of rebellion however that sort of
walk would lead to a grand Insurrection
where they band together the like 200
000 people on tiers four and five and
then the ship again who goes Kaboom so
there is there's a lot of elements
coming together here specifically around
Moreno actually I feel like the deeper
we dive into this the more she seems to
to be portrayed as the Catalyst of
Destruction even more so than the
succession War I'm oddly excited to be
getting some serratic backstory though
if it wasn't clear already that he was
probably the major Prince of the Ark
then it should be now and the story
about hyper focusing on the gun assembly
provides a lot of context as to how he's
able to become such a sudden nen Prodigy
he just has that correct mixture of raw
talent and fierce Drive which supposedly
contradicts his childhood friends here I
mean they'll demonstrate pretty
phenomenal intelligence but if I
understand correctly they're all
deliberately keeping their distance so
that they can remain a surroundings
friends and we only know the names of
like two or three of them at the moment
but I find this group fascinating and
there are some really great potential
here for example I'd love to see what
it's like for just regular intelligent
humans to be going up against a band of
dumbass menus and humans how does a
conflict like that pan out I don't know
but I'm Keen to see it also one of them
is almost certainly going to be infected
by Morena right in this chapter there's
a lot of what I refer to as plot [ __ ]
happening mirena's [ __ ] around the
idea of I need to convert one of the
prince's guards and these friends of the
relevant Prince [ __ ] around the idea
of whom Miranda needs to be stopped and
furthermore I wonder if we could learn n
somehow so there's a lot of plot teasing
that sets up this almost perfect
scenario where one gets infected and
then has a tricky situation to navigate
being under the abilities of Morena but
still having that loyalty to saradnik oh
and also any one of these characters
learning men is a game changer they all
seem to have that kind of intellect on
par with a character like karapika so
give one of them access to nen and that
is a whole new series protagonist and I
wouldn't be surprised if one of these
figures ended up being the sort of
comogy of this Arc someone with a
surprise empathetic link to our main
antagonist who even though seradnik is
an objectively evil man somehow manages
to humanize him a bit maybe or not it
could even be a reverse comedy maybe
these characters will serve as a sort of
final barrier for seradnik to break to
truly embrace the monster that he's
become slash always was either way all I
know is that my first thought when we
get done with six to seven new
characters is so almost all of you are
probably going to die right and I don't
feel like that's any different here six
new protagonists it's all just so much
to juggle especially when they all have
effectively the same Mission so we can
simplify that down to maybe one or two
with some brutal fight battling they go
on to speak about later in this chapter
and we even get some flashbacks of her
and just as a quick recap beta was one
of ceradnik's bodyguards prior to the
whole Dark Continent thing which I point
out because there's often some confusion
that she's from the hunter Association
because she's currently teaching
saradniknen full disclosure I don't know
how or why she and at least one of the
other surrounding bodyguards already
knows then especially because theta's
friend in this chapter knows absolutely
nothing about it in general though it's
just really sporadic and kind of random
which bodyguards know then and which
ones don't so I I generally try not to
think too much about it but there's also
a mention of a tattoo artist member of
the hailedi family who I suspect is this
guy we saw him making an artwork out of
one of the bodies that saranic managed
to acquire via arts and kill murder and
I suppose he's relevant because he's the
reason why Miranda may know the names
and faces of this special striving
Strike Force and may even make an active
effort to Target them it's also insane
to think about though we are what like
50 chapters into this Arc and we are
still introducing new characters not
only new characters but seemingly
incredibly pivotal ones I keep saying
this but it's like Chimera ants all over
again which is exciting because I do
think that this Arc has the potential to
be the best since the ants but I do
worry about exactly how long it's gonna
take to finish all of a sudden 10 or
even 20 chapters really doesn't seem
like a lot but I'm definitely invested
and very eager to keep following this
increasingly convoluted story